hey guys i'm ryan right hey guys i'm
andrew andrew and i are here today
because I have waited around all day for
this [ __ ] trailer to drop a step out
for a little bit after waiting in my
home for seven hours of course it drops
then of course but I've been waiting
like at least a year for this thing dude
oh yeah ever since that uh ever since
that awesome leaked test footage I love
you Wade Wilson we can fight this you're
right
cancers only my liver lungs prostate and
brain all things I can live without what
if I told you we can make you better
you're a fighter we can give you
abilities most men only dream of make
you a superhero you just promise you'll
do right by me so I can do right by
someone else please don't make the
supersuit green or animated one thing
that never survives this place is a
sense of humor we'll see about that pop
spicing oh come on you know leave me all
alone here with less angry Rosie
O'Donnell I'm gonna shoot baby dingus
dad Bessy in the backdrop I wanna make
your mother
wait you may be wondering why the red
suit well that's so bad guys can't see
me bleed this guy's got the right idea
he wore the brown pants oh [ __ ] express
some rage
how many oh no way
it reeks like old lady pants in here
sounds like you have a dick in your
mouth Oh [ __ ] you are hard to
look at like a testicle with teeth looks
like Freddy Krueger face-fucked a
topographical map of Utah
Wow
oh I'm touching myself tonight give it
to you give it to you
you are auntie look like an avocado had
sex with an older avocado thank you
can we watch it again yeah I'm down yeah
good I love you Wade Wilson we can fight
this
I like having trailers waiting with my
donut for us to yeah although theory
without what if I told you we can make
you better
they're like it eats it like this is
gonna be a traditional yeah most it's
really clever make you a superhero you
just promise you'll do right by me so I
can do right by someone else and please
don't make the supersuit green or
animated one thing that never survives
history it's a sense of humor oh I just
got the green joke yes
angry Rosie O'Donnell
yeah I wanna shoot baby vineya dad Jesse
in the back
ruff I wanna paint your mother for
love the look at the suit panel agree
wait you may be wondering why the red
suit well that's so bad guys can't see
me bleed this guy's got the right idea
he wore the brown pants daddy needs to
express some rage
enemy no matter how many chance of a
gear wheel tray
that's cool like las doce reeks like old
lady pants in here sounds like you have
a dick in your mouth Oh [ __ ] you
are hard to look at like a testicle with
teeth look like Freddy Krueger
face-fucked a topographical map of Utah
exactly
not the plate stay
I love that shot oh I'm touching myself
tonight give it to you give it to you go
give it you are aunty look like an
avocado had sex with an older avocado
thank you
Ryan Reynolds was like born to play this
role was he not absolutely I can't wait
to see his portrayal I mean because that
first version and x-men origins
Wolverine was ridiculous so they shut
his mouth at the end that's whose
character is he's got a big mouth he's
the Merc with a mouth yeah because I
remember the little bit where he was
just wade wilson in excellent origins
beginning yeah he was great as that part
though and everyone wanted to see that
Deadpool and they want to Ryan Reynolds
to be in it so I'm so glad that they
brought this out finally they didn't do
some dead bull reboot and cast someone
else
they gave the fans what they want this
is r-rated there's cool violence in the
trailer I'm kind of hoping there's a lot
more you know I'm hoping that we get a
lot like a simple so I want a lot more
violence you know I thought the action
the hand-to-hand combat from what we saw
in the trailer was fantastic it even
looked a little remind me a little of
the hand and combat we got in Captain
America the Winter Soldier that
fantastic combat didn't look like you
know a lot of that stuff and it's not a
lot of CGI it's like they could have
easily CG Deadpool throughout most as we
lose you could tell there's either Ryan
Reynolds or a stunt man on drink that
suit actually doing stuff instead of it
just being you know computer-generated
and the part with Colossus I thought
that was so cool it's a good look he
looks good it's a great time so yeah
x-men interest rather than showing like
Hugh Jackman of yours I'm hoping it's
more than just a good trailer so much
because this is their first trailer I'm
sold on it already but all the stuff
that we want to see him do like the
self-awareness a lot of like the nerd
humor aching the wall breaking the
fourth wall like that is the stuff I
really want to get a lot of out of this
film you know it's weird it's like you
want a lot of it same time you don't
want too much of it you know yes but
you're definitely gonna want it and the
dialogue of Ryan rounds delivery is just
it's like yeah that's [ __ ] Deadpool
talking right now absolutely in complete
agreement the biggest even though this
isn't like a told comma you know there's
gonna be a lot of comedy in this film
obviously so I hope we're not seeing all
the jokes in the trailer I don't think
we are cuz you know with Ryan Reynolds
and TJ and all you know you're gonna get
a lot of improv so I'm sure there's
going to jokes be ad in the film why
can't we see it again I just hope
they're not they're not putting the best
jokes in the
the trailers I just want a couple that's
it and then save the good ones for the
film because I'm sold he sold me a
Deadpool in this trailer was amazing I
forgot the character's name but the one
who TJ Miller place is lo diesel yeah he
acts is like the arson arsonist for
Deadpool yeah basically like he he's
like his sidekick I guess you would say
no so like I guess he collects his
weapons for him and yeah I'm sure the
people in the comments are gonna you
know exactly say what he does exactly
but basically the sidekick collects
weapons for him you know they have a lot
of Panter between as you could see in
the trailer so I'm sure again the scenes
between them is going to be money
chemistry golden that we're gonna laugh
like crazy
yeah desert those are two very skilled
people at comedy oh yeah but I bet they
they improv like crazy when they were
doing their scenes together
yeah let's seem like Judd Apatow died
look at that time yeah I can't even wait
to see just like when the film comes out
like on DVD and blu-ray good enough talk
a little I can't wait to see the deleted
scenes and some of the outtakes just the
comedy and the improv oh my bed's gonna
be so funny I mean yeah movie looks
[ __ ] sweet I'm sold on I've been sold
on this since I heard it was announced
you know like I would watch this
regardless of trailer lovely test
footage sold me so much oh no that was
so cool despite the copyright strike I
still love that footage yeah the end
though so we saw in the trailer we saw
some of that footage - yeah a little bit
so yeah they made a lot better and semi
of course but they were in the Escalade
he's like chopping at the bit and then
he does though yeah we was drawing and
stuff yeah yeah that was really cool
like how they include that they didn't
like you know they're not done with that
scene like I've included in the film
that's really cool so it's gonna be nice
to see the finished product on that
scene especially it will be nice to see
the finished product manager I agree it
will be anyway guys if you're new to the
channel you can subscribe to the real
rejects you can check out andrew on
twitter egg or 7-eleven what's a tour
7-eleven that is my first name and
middle of my my my last name the first
few letters of my last name why didn't
you go with a horse 69 because i was
already taken so sorry eight horse 69
would have worked a lot bad did you know
popular that name is you know I was gone
already when I try it's up alright and
you can follow us on Facebook Instagram
Twitter vine and periscope he only has
Twitter but I got all
[ __ ] Abraham seal us seus hello the real
rejects my youtube name is YouTube's
little helper I specialize in helping
the people of YouTube find good
entertainment and help youtubers get
more subs I don't need your help
I'm doing fine without you Abraham I
also share some of my own stuff and
always put the place where you can get
it in the description
I really appreciate if you would give me
a shout-out thanks for reading abraham
CS it sounds like he's trying to pitch
me on something Andrew ya was gonna say
are you helping him or is he hoping you
I don't know it sounds like he is
offering to help give me like better
entertainment better subs you know what
we need black strippers if you can find
a way to glue if there's one thing the
real rejects has been missing it's a
black person we need more black people
are you black listen dude Abraham
looking at your photo right now I know
what it's like to eat away at your
emotions I know what it's like but I'm
telling you Carl's jr. he's not your
friend Carl he's a bad guy the Burger
King wants you home Ronald McDonald
wants to touch you don't know why that's
what he wants to do so it's time to slim
down my friend like me don't look at you
don't